[Musique]
celle épilogue d'une carrière qui aura
duré plus de 40 ans la famille de bruce
willis a annoncé hier sur instagram sa
maladie une phase i qui le précipite à
arrêter le cinéma on lui a récemment
diagnostiqué une aphasie qui affectent
ses capacités cognitives
après mûre réflexion
bruce renonce à sa carrière qui a tant
compté pour lui le fasi est un
dysfonctionnement du système nerveux
central qui affecte la parole
deux autres trois autres dispositions
auxquelles sa dope sa dose par donc vous
vous souvenez 1 c
ces luttes sela 6 la sûreté dans la
constitution contre la dette et son
maintien
une faille dès la fin de sa hausse il
n'y aura pas de vacances parlementaires
parce que on va travailler
on va travailler dur si beaucoup ont
réagi sur le poste de son ex femme demi
moore par des émaux j affectueux de
cindy crawford à julianne moore un
message a été très en vue celui du
réalisateur night shyamalan qui l'a
dirigé dans sixième sens ou encore dans
la trilogie incassable il sera toujours
ce héros sur cette affiche sur mon mur
quand j'étais enfant un héros qui après
42 ans de carrière et plus de 100 films
de livrer un nouveau combat dans cet
hôpital de liverpool lorsqu'un patient
passe un scanner ou une irm les
infirmières doivent d'abord lui demander
si il ou elle est enceinte peu importe
qu'il s'agisse d'un homme ou d'une femme
objectif va être inclusif ne pas juger
le patient selon son genre
les mots hommes et femmes ont été banni
du langage un des infirmières remplacé
par le mot individus il faut donc
demander aux individus s'ils sont en
saint raphaël à ce niveau la bêtise
c'est qu'on
aimerait avoir vous pour vos pubs parce
qu'on les adore et je vais démontrer
d'ailleurs à virginie marie essaiera
regardez les pubs de cette franchise
d'épilation c'est ici que j'entretiens
montpetit gazon on va c'est pas mal
ce petit
monde qui va plaire je suis sûr à mary
une deuxième puis regardez marie une
boule de poils peut en cacher une autre
[Rires]
qari sami belloumi nous
caresser
câline et demi nous car et c'est très
bien
[Musique]
les gens qui râlent comme pas possible
mais on a rasé mon grand c'est pas toi
tu dis si tu sais moi thirard mon allure
on va faire le chemin tranquille ou pour
que l'udc est facile avec son plateau de
pas content d'être avec moi mais c'est
comme ça vous voir tu vas faire un petit
peu de marche avec moi ouais
oui
aussi je suis le faire chacun son
tempérament ne jugez pas les gens sur
les apparences moi je ne vous juge pas
sur les appareils non je vous aime bien
pourtant y'a rien qui pousse
vous avez dire comme ça la france on va
passer donc à la question suivante en
vue chez vous ne regardez pas lieu parce
que je lui ai promis que si elle posait
des questions trop tranchées je lui
rendrai la monnaie voilà un email
c'est là une chose si la
chanter quoi nous avons entamé et par là
même
la tranche a sonné quant à lima pendant
que st chamond ça paie cher c'est avec
un mois plein de souvenirs de jeunesse
et la chanteuse sheila sheila
est aussi jolie que l'autre
vous a parlé maintenant il faut une miss
france plus féministe était alors je
prends raccourci mais dans le spectacle
je dis maintenant ça suffit il faut le
dire en garde miss france pour voir des
pulsions avoir des femmes intelligentes
on regarde questions pour un champion
mais mais jeudi la réalité à un moment
on est là pour élire miss france le dire
c est ce serait pareil pour mister
france voilà on voit toujours pour une
plastique au départ je m'en fous quand
je garde miss france que lé un bac +2 ou
tracé je trouve ça ridicule et hypocrite
en fait voilà